save is in Maryland eyes EV are you all
on yourself better than I deserve what's
up so my wife and I are baby step two we
both share a car that's about 13 years
old I just recently put $1,000 towards
it and it should hopefully keep going
but we have a tax refund coming up that
I'm looking towards three options either
putting it towards the last $10,000 we
have in debt for my student loan either
it's a save for a car for when this one
eventually dies or it's a safe for my
wife who's going to be going to
hopefully go to PA school and out of U K
years time okay don't need to do PA
school til we get out of debt and save
the money to do it so that would not be
on the list for this money yeah how big
is the tax refund looks like about four
thousand this year and I've adjusted it
for this coming year using the IRS
calculator so I won't have that again
next year
good for you well done all right so
4,000 bucks I wouldn't use it what about
a second car I was kind of thinking I
was going to hear that happen I happen
to work fairly local and we're managing
with one car do you think is a reason
for us to get a second car no I'm just I
kind of thought you were gonna bring it
up it's okay I'm fine cuz you know look
I'm trying I don't want to get into that
so I don't know I don't want you instead
I don't want you in debt you have your
$1,000 starter emergency fund right yes
okay and you only have ten thousand
dollars in debt left correct
and what's your household income I'm I'm
making fifty five thousand and my wife
right now is in school or cash flowing
that for her to get her bachelor's
degree okay so if you put the four
thousand towards the debt how quickly is
the other six thousand gone were I'm
really pushing and aiming to get it done
less than a year's time before she gets
her bachelor's degree six thousand
dollars in a year um
yes no that's wussy we're not doing that
you need to do better than that it's
only 500 bucks a month dude are you guys
living on a written budget we are living
on a written budget unfortunately where
we're living we don't really have any
options to move elsewhere so my rent is
$1,200 we I do have a written budget so
we write and that is I just I want you
to get that done and like I was hoping
you're gonna tell me like three or four
months I really could push for that what
I do I guess there's a couple thousand
dollars let's say right now in my
checking account that I wasn't sure how
to touch but now using what you just
said I can just throw that at the debt
in which case they'll knock you down
even more so yeah and let's just get
that what I want what I'm trying to do
is get that thing done so that we can
move up in car a little bit with cash
and get your emergency fund done so that
we can get her start saving towards PA
school I'm trying to lay out a timeline
of dominoes here that work together get
out of got it and that's what I was
seeing mathematically in my head the
faster I can get rid of that 10 grand so
I would use the 4 grand towards the 10
grand but under the under the assumption
that we're gonna go crazy and get the
rest of that done so that we can get you
a little better car because that's what
you're worried about and then get your
emergency fund built on up and then
you'll be in a position to save towards
her PA school because you'll have a
little wiggle room got it and yeah
that's exactly how I would do it but but
I would not do that if it's gonna take
you I might I might rethink that if it's
gonna take you 12 14 months to get rid
of $6,000 because that's a long time for
this whole car to have to stay together
I hear what are you saying I'm trying to
get I'm trying to get rid of debt fast
enough so I can get you into this out of
this car before it blows up on you makes
sense to me that's my plan and you know
because the longer you drag this out the
more we got to rethink oh we probably
just need to change cars if it drags out
if you told me you had $60,000 in debt I
tell you to beYOU some money to upgrade
your car
so that you can make the slog through
the rest of the 60,000 but we got six
thousand there's ten thousand with four
to throw at it and a couple out of the
checking account and you know I think we
can get there before the car leaves us
before it goes to car heaven